[Music]
this podcast has bad words
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists we often get stuck
when we're unwilling or unable to
question the beliefs opinions and
worldviews that have shaped us
but if we can't let go of old attitudes
then aren't we forever anchored to the
past and if we're anchored how can we
possibly move forward that's what we're
talking about today on the show with
michael gunger michael is the host of
the liturgist podcast he's also the
author of this beautiful book if you're
watching on youtube i'll hold it up here
it's called this
subtitle is becoming free and that's
what we're going to talk about today
we're going to talk about this as
opposed to that we're talking about
becoming free we're going to talk about
letting go of beliefs and then this
thursday on the minimalist private
podcast ryan and i are going to talk to
michael about the courage it takes to
walk away from
your past life even
if it pisses off a large number of your
friends and and family and even a large
chunk of your giant audience michael
you check that out patreon.com the
minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me
advertisements suck
we do this with audiences true yeah um
michael thank you so much for being here
brother thank you for having me oh
pleasure this is uh such a great book i
thought
before we get into our first question
here from barbara on twitter let's open
the podcast with a poem
and so you open your book with a poem
and i thought this would be the most
appropriate place to start would you
mind reading this for us sure
this
is all there is
yesterday and tomorrow we're just wounds
and stories
this
is not all there is
there is also that
desiring milk while you drink water
that is suffering
of course that is absurd for this is all
there is
does this confuse you beloved
perhaps i could say it a different way
if i ascend to the heavens you were
there
if i make my bed in hell you were there
um
this book is about well it's about this
and um
we have a great source of misery people
often start listening to the minimalist
podcast because the average american
household has 300 000 items in it
because wow
we're all searching for that
through things
now that's in our culture but many years
before
cheap plastic goods were available for
next to free with one-click shipping
we were still searching for that in
a multitude of ways
so
we're gonna get some audience questions
here in a moment but i thought maybe you
could just talk about
the um
the impetus of this book it seemed to me
like you were going through some some
great suffering
that led to uh an awakening of sorts
yeah
thank you
i um
the impetus was
in part kind of trying to process what i
was experiencing i've found as a
musician
that
writing songs about what i'm going
through actually kind of clarifies for
me it kind of helps me
actually experience what i'm going
through in a way you know so
uh writing this book was kind of like
everything had been shifting in
internally for me
and try like
writing was part of how i
kept noticing what was happening me was
kind of like the observation
of the evolution and it was
and it was uh
so much of my life has been
sharing my internal experience through
some sort of art form
and
that's just
kind of how i'm
wired and and so this was
a book that was about
about this and about my own personal
journey
of learning to
embrace the moment
that i live in
and and even in the writing of the book
and like it it even kind of was a
spiritual practice for me in itself like
it just kept reminding me
and kept bringing me to this
[Music]
it seems to me that
the suffering
that we are all
experiencing virtually all of us there's
some there's a low-grade misery that
permeates most of our days
and it often has to do with a
a striving
for something other than
this
and i'm sure you experienced that in
your world you grew up in a
conservatively conservative christian
world and sort of ascended the ranks
became quote unquote successful right
had all the trappings of success whether
it's material success but also the sort
of applause and adulation literal
applause
awards and people recognizing you on the
street and saying oh
he has it figured out
he has that
thing that i want he has achieved the
the thing that if i could just achieve
that it would make me happy and in the
book you talk about you got everything
you ever wanted and it kind of made you
miserable yeah
isn't it like
it is
the
the gift there's some great quote i
don't know why i'm bringing it up
because i don't remember it but it is
basically like
uh
i wish everyone would get everything
they want so they could see that it
doesn't work or whatever or something
something like that and it is it is
really like
when i finally got the things that i had
spent so much energy on
to try to fill that
void to try to
uh
be okay
and it didn't work then it just kind of
left me with like
well what do you do now what do you
this hopelessness and
i think you
it's so interesting that what you're
talking about how how many items people
have in their houses and stuff it that
seems to me just to be
the inner world writ large it's like
that's what we do is we've always that's
what the human ego does with thoughts
that's what and beliefs
and our attachments
to what how we want our to our desires
and how we want the world to be
and we just collect and fill our minds
with this
this
mess of
um
thoughts looking for identity to solve
some sort of existential problem that we
feel inside and so it's kind of no
surprise that our we do that outside of
our bodies too we're like it's it's
trying to find something else
to fix to get me away from this
yeah
in your book you talk about
the not okayness i think is
is how you phrase it
and
uh i think that's yeah that's why you
know internally and externally why we
clutter our lives up is because there's
a sense of not okayness yeah
and yeah you did such a good job of in
your book addressing the
i don't know i mean and correct me if
i'm wrong but the book kind of
leads you to this
um accepting the not okayness
rather than avoiding it or well here's
how i here's how it became okay
he even asked that question right what
do i do now presupposing what there is
something to do
right now part of that is the limitation
of language right yeah but
but quite often we think oh i did it all
i got the result that i thought would
make me happy it didn't
so i need to do something else i pursued
happiness in the wrong way
so i'll just head this direction and
there will be happiness and of course we
try that in the book you tried about a
dozen different ways right throughout
your life you we try these different
things to make us happy to grab the
happiness that's already there to you
can only be uncovered yeah
and when you get down to what we're
running from
you really look at it it's kind of a
boogeyman scenario because it feels
it
it's kind of embarrassingly
animal and it's just a sensation like
when we get down to
why am i feeling my life with all this
needless stuff or why am i
scrambling to believe and
when we get down into the this moment
like what's actually happening right now
that i'm trying to avoid
and it's just sensation in my body it's
just
like
oh is there a little sense of fear or
or sadness and am i really unwilling to
feel like 15 seconds of sadness if you
really feel an emotion fully it doesn't
usually last that long right it can be
it feels like when you're starting to
feel it like it's going to be this
infinite wave of sensation and it's
going to send me into hell for all of
eternity but when you get down to it's
just a temporary passing vapor of
sensation
but we don't want to feel it we don't
want to feel what's actually happening
in this moment
because it's a lot it can it could feel
like a lot so we go through this crazy
amount of activity to avoid feeling
this moment
including filling our lives with endless
activity and stuff and filling our minds
with endless beliefs and and
workarounds and loopholes and
and
repressions and and
projections and
and really make it down like
or i could just
feel the sensation
yes and move on and feel that sensation
and the ironic thing is when you say
okay i'm willing to feel
i'm wheeling i'm willing to feel
what it's like to be in this body in
this moment
and that including its pain
including its
all this and all the sensations there
might be a little discomfort for a
minute but strangely and ironically it
actually does
become
blissful and like free and full of love
and
even anger even like we mentioned this
on the maximalist podcast but the um
maharaji said i love suffering it brings
me so close to god
and when you even find the kind of like
dark kinky pleasures of the things that
we think we don't want to feel
you can find this underlying
beauty to life
yeah that
that really i think is what it means to
be free
well let's uh move on to some questions
we have here let's uh let's go over to
twitter barbara has a question for us
how do we know if a belief no longer
serves us do we wait until that belief
is tested or should we always be looking
for a sign
michael i gotta ask the question maybe
if i were to rephrase the question do
beliefs ever serve us
yeah
well that's when we get down to like
what are you wanting if you're wanting
to experience some
suffering they might serve you
incredibly well
[Laughter]
if we don't have a presuppose that what
do you want and not immoralizing of what
you want because either really not moral
if you want to suffer it really isn't a
problem
that's apparently
we like it
without a doubt because we do so many
things that make us suffer so it in fact
if an alien came down here and they saw
us these people really enjoy suffering
they are addicted to misery yeah
for sure and so i guess maybe the
question i would ask you here is what is
that relationship between belief and
suffering yeah
it depends you have to define the words
you know and i i think there's some
element of
belief that there's there's necessary
assumptions that we make
um
you know all of us are trusting each
other
in this room to not be murderous
you know psychopaths to each other right
now we're all like we're probably going
to be cool we're going to be like
and there's a level that's kind of a
belief about that like i believe you're
decent human beings so you need to
operate in the world you need to have
some assumptions or trust but i like
those words personally more belief tends
to be a word in my experience but i grew
up in a very belief-centric kind of
community
that was really about
closing your fists
and being like
doesn't matter what
the science says it doesn't matter
what those people say over there we
believe and it was an identity thing and
it was a
um it was a closing down it was a no of
sorts yeah and i
i think that
doesn't ever create anything but more no
it's just it
if you're going no i don't care i
believe
um you're shut you're you're resisting
reality and that is the essence of
suffering the no to reality that like i
don't want to experience this
because otherwise it's just sensation
like pain if you resist pain and you
don't want to be feeling pain then
there's that level of
mental suffering that kind of makes it
worse
um
much worse if it's just a you know
i have some stories about that in the
book that are little graphics but
about some times in my life where there
was like some pain and no resistance and
it was fine and and other times where it
wasn't probably that much pain but i was
resisting and it was hell yeah
and um
so when beliefs
if you're me by beliefs you mean
when do you clamp down
and form and base your identity in some
abstract thought
about how reality is and when does that
serve you i don't think it serves
anything but you getting the experience
of suffering that you're looking for
[Music]
oh that's so good man i i think about
this question reminds me of when we had
jp sears uh as a guest in atlanta oh wow
it's like five years ago yeah and
someone asked about beliefs and he was
like
he's a he's a comic
and he's like i really think
you need to believe your beliefs
and you need to look at those and live
your life with those
but don't hold on to him too tightly so
he said have your beliefs but don't
believe your beliefs
so good and
and what i appreciate about about that
is
what he's saying there is similar to
what you're saying is you'll notice when
a belief pops up
but clinging to it is what gives us that
because a belief is going to happen if
you're raised in a society none of us
are an island raised on an island and
even if you were on an island even that
ecosystem would then shape your beliefs
and so your beliefs have been shaped not
by your free will
if there ever were such a thing but by
everything that got you to where you are
right now yeah and you can recognize
those you can have your beliefs without
believing your beliefs yeah i had a
conversation with a friend of mine
brianna on our podcast at the end of
this last season about belief and how
make-believe to me is kind of like
the highest form of belief when we're
when we realize like we're making
believe
like a kid let's make believe and you
need to do it to play the game yeah you
can't play a game without
so we all need to believe in that way we
all need to make believe
that
money's real and that
democracy is real
equality all the things all our words
and our ideas we gotta we gotta believe
those are things
but
if
if we lose sight of the fact that we're
making those beliefs for a specific
desire with a specific outcome desired
then they become prisons then they
become this
abstract reality that's outside of
ourselves that i'm now disempowered
because it's
contr i'm in its control rather than
realizing i'm
actively
make-believing
all of this yeah it's all fundamentally
make right right and that's not
pejorative we're not saying oh because
that could be seen that way oh just make
believe right your beliefs they're just
make-believe or you could yeah my
beliefs are just make-believe it's
active
make-believe is active
yes you're you're you're engaged in the
process you're like what kind of meaning
am i assigning to my life and what kind
of concepts and technologies
am i using
uh how am i building my life and how is
it related to my desires as opposed to
if it's just a belief
that you think
you need to have because it's true
objectively now you've taken yourself
out of the equation
and so now you're you're not aware of
your unconscious desires that are
leading you to that belief in the first
place and so now you're you're
disempowering yourself you are
you're assigning you're passing the buck
of accountability of responsibility
and of joy yes
yeah and also the if something is true
it's true regardless of your belief
you know this is always funny to me that
when we talk about like it's easy to
sort of point fingers and sneer at like
someone who's a flat earther right
because they believe the earth is flat
wow okay i believe the earth is round
but the earth is round
regardless whether or not i believe that
my belief changes tomorrow
the the truth doesn't change i just
start to
have a a concept about something that is
now untrue and i think quite often most
of our beliefs this make-believe that we
we have it's usually someone else's
beliefs who are thrust thrust upon us
right so now all of a sudden i'm
believing all these other things these
other people believe i don't necessarily
believe in my heaven i haven't stopped
to consider what is true i've simply
been handed a set of beliefs by a
religion by a culture by a society by a
peer group by co-workers etc and now i'm
holding on to those because you know
some person confidently said that this
was their belief
[Music]
it kind of if i could push a little bit
on the objective
issue though is is that it i do think
that because we assume
the earth is round for instance
like the earth is what it is
but even when i say round
that
i'm signifying something that i have a
concept of round
and i still if i totally displace myself
from that like i think that's what we
see in the uncertainty principle is like
the observer actually can't ever
fully
you're never out of the room right
you're never observing something
objectively you can't the observer
affects the observed because it is in a
way the observed that it's observing
itself the universe is observing itself
yes and
and so the earth is round
meaning so if your beliefs
uh
if your beliefs about the earth's shape
change
and we have some measurements about the
earth
the measurements aren't going to change
based on your beliefs right but there's
also a level of saying
when i say the earth is round i gotta
realize that that means something to me
that's not ultimately objectively true
yes the earth is not round or is not
flat
the earth is
the earth is not a word it's a
are great with this kind of thing like
there's a
tree falling in the forest yeah if it's
good does it make a sound if there's
nobody around to hear it yeah um
it's like is the earth round if you're
not saying it's round if you're not
witnessing is around right yeah right um
we got some more questions here let's
move on to our callers if you have a
question or comment for our podcast give
us a call 406.
[Music]
or you can email a voice memo to podcast
at theminimalists.com
we have a question here from elizabeth
in gainesville florida how do you deal
with depression and anxiety when you
were raised in a family that promoted
both
do you
have to walk away from that or is there
another approach that maybe you just
don't know about
so michael what elizabeth is asking here
is about
yeah she grew up in a family that
promotes
anxiety depression
and
at first that sounds so absurd
but our culture seems to promote
anxiety and depression and
and
i want to be clear though those things
aren't inherently bad either in fact
you'll probably get more of it if you
try to avoid it
now you talk a lot about this in the
book about
dealing with certain neuroses and
and uh anxieties especially
with respect to the world around you and
and dealing with your own privileges but
also your own pains
and so
if you were to talk to elizabeth here
she's asking a question about
about dealing with this i don't know
that we want to deal with it per se
i think we want to do something
different yeah
when it comes
again down to what the actual experience
that you're experiencing elizabeth
[Music]
is it
depression and anxiety like if you look
in this very moment
or is it sensation
in this very moment
not as the the stories the words that we
use
can be helpful for
diagnosing things and coming up with
plans and how can we treat certain
things and all that's fine and good but
there's an element
i think to some especially anxiety
um anxiety is often
a fruit of us not wanting to feel what's
actually happening underneath
the anxiety
like there's
and there are some um
psychological
theories
that i'm i are what i'm this is not my
field by any means
um
[Music]
of expertise but
the
the anxiety is often talked about as
sort of like a secondary tier of
emotions it's not a primary emotion
anxiety is often a cover-up for
some deeper experience that we're not
wanting to have and not wanting to look
at and so anxiety kind of hums on the
surface as we're trying to look away and
not feel that grief
or that
anger or some of the primary emotions
that can be big and that we've learned
from
our society as we've been socialized
that you can't feel those big emotions
otherwise you won't
you'll lose
safety in the tribe like we all have
learned like shut that down
you're that's too excited
or sure you can be you can't be that
angry otherwise you're going to lose
your attachment figures
in your life
so we've all learned and it's part of
being socialized how to kind of control
our emotions and there's an element of
that that's
fine and healthy but but if we never let
ourselves experience
the fullness of what what's wanting to
be felt in our bodies
then it kind of does create this
secondary layer this hum of constant
uh
it's almost like the the
the gas gauge light or something like
dinging or the seat belt the seat belt
ding ding ding ding ding ding like hey
your seat belts not on ding ding ding
ding and anxiety like hey you're not
feeling you're not feeling the sadness
you're not here and the way to fix that
isn't to well you know what i should do
just take out that alarm from my car
and that's how we try to deal with
anxiety is like
i will do these three things it's
essentially going to remove the alarm no
this is the alarm that's saying there's
something else to be felt right
yeah so if you get down to and that's
again this moment
if you like there's no we even try to
like push that away okay yeah i got to
figure out how to feel it no no right
now just
what's happening in your body and if you
didn't resist that for a minute
right
one minute you just invited the full
brunt of it
um uh
just watch see what happened and a lot
of the
even the anxiety itself accepting the
the yes like going back to that i love
suffering so much it brings me so close
to god
i if you can love anxiety so much it
brings you to your emotions
you love depression so much it brings
you into your experience
then it kind of takes its power
and imprisonment
away
and and just becomes another sensation
that's all it's all temporary the whole
universe
is temporary like all it's all passing
nothing lasts forever
so
if you just don't try to make it last
forever and just experience it
um
you can get on with it and there's no
you don't have to fight against
depression and anxiety
and you don't have to hold on to it you
can just notice if it's there and then
it'll do what it does and move on as
everything else in the universe does
yeah you can't be in the moment tomorrow
that's what we often that's what we're
going for right is
is you know i will be in the moment you
know at 8 a.m and 4 p.m during my 12
minutes of meditation
and
not to say there's anything wrong with
meditating
but
meditativeness is actually sort of what
you are are going for what you're
talking about here when we talk about
being present or being in the moment
and you can't prescribe that right good
luck all right well hurry up and be in
the moment right now
what you're talking about when you're
talking about being in the moment is
you're talking about not suppressing
whatever you are experiencing yeah
yeah
not running away from it and i think you
can feel what it feels like to run aw it
feels like anxiety it feels like
get it trying to get away from your own
self
yeah which is
a pointless endeavor
because you can't right just makes it
worse just makes it worse yeah
oh man i uh
so one thing that helps me kind of live
with some of these negative emotions um
[Music]
is finding
some sort of appreciation so i carried a
lot of resentment
from being raised jehovah's witness and
how it's like you know my dad and i have
a very poor relationship because of this
religion and the beliefs and
and i
carried this uh like i said resentment
of like oh if it wasn't for the religion
you know then and i had this almost
spiteful attitude about it
but i have um been able to move past
that with some
therapy by the way it's not like i just
woke up one morning and i was like oh
now i feel better
it was talking this out with a
professional
and um
i can look at that
upbringing i can look at the
you know all the morals and everything
that was thrust upon me i can look at
that and say oh wow like it created who
i am today
and there are and that's what i love
about your book is you talk about
some of the things that you still carry
from these stories that make you
um
enjoy life and to make you the man you
are today
so i don't know if there's something
there for elizabeth but
finding a way to look at that and say oh
you know what thanks for that symptom i
appreciate this symptom of anxiety and
thanks for this
symptom of you know whatever negative
emotion it is instead of yeah instead of
trying to resist it try to find a
some bit of not just acceptance but
appreciation for it
thanks for the alarm yeah and without
calling it a negative emotion yeah right
right because even that now all of a
sudden taints our experience because as
soon as anxiety is a negative emotion or
depression is a negative emotion the
question is how can i get rid of this as
soon as possible how can i set this on
fire how can i ignore this how can i
avoid this how can i run away from this
and all of those are simply asking how
can i not experience this yeah
i think there are certain big emotions
especially grief
but a lot of them that in our society in
particular
have been really repressed and really
made socially unacceptable
and i read this book this year that i
really liked called the smell of rain on
dust and he's talking about
how
grief and praise are kind of the
opposite ends of the same coin and we
don't have
our experience of wonder
of life gets limited because we kind of
quash squash it all into this gray like
we don't want to feel the full brunt of
the pain and the grief
of existence and all that we've
lost
to make this world as it is now like we
have so many wonderful
technologies and
and advantages to living right now we've
also lost a lot and we don't allow
ourselves to like grieve
some of the lost connection we have with
animals and with the earth and with each
other and
with life in a way
and it kind of just numbs us to not just
the sadness but to the other side of the
coin which is he calls praise or wonder
or
this sort of like miraculous experience
of life that can be so
beautiful and because it it all kind of
squashes into this anxiety
blah
right yeah but and you talk about this a
bit in your book and and i assume from
your research you've
you know more about this but like
buddhists or neo-buddhists
they they do seem to do the same thing
though where there is
uh an avoidance and avoidance probably
the wrong word but there is
certainly not an embracing of excitement
because excitement is
synonymous with suffering to them in a
way
and so i'm wondering about reconciling
that because in the book you sort of you
you go through atheism uh you're an
atheist for a while you're a christian
for a while you're a muslim for a while
um but very devout for that yeah at that
moment fully committed let's clarify a
homeland tv show based
islamic follow-up yes
and um appropriating from a tv show yeah
yeah
there there are sort of uh hindu maxims
throughout et cetera et cetera and what
you realize there are these different
wisdom traditions who
have different perspectives that sort of
point toward the same truth
in a way and
and yet i'm wondering
i'm wondering
because you experience all of um these
different
perspectives
um
was there a
a deeper truth that you came out of this
with
all these perspectives and languages i
really am liking the term technologies
to think of
even like religions philosophies words
practices spiritual practices
because if if
if you kind of took like the the
minimalist
philosophy of like looking at your your
life and what's serving you if we did
that with our beliefs and our spiritual
practices and we're like here's a thing
that's in my life
how am i using it am i using it
or is it just something that's
cluttering my mind
um
then it allows you
if to me the truth
the capital t truth is
not something that can be spoken i love
how it the dao is the dao that can be
spoken is not the true dao the opening
line yeah that that's the opening line
of the qing and i think that's one of
the
that's his that's kind of as close to
true as language can be for me it's like
yeah
uh it's pointing to it the language's
own
nature yeah which is like appointing
itself it's like this is the pointing
it's not
the pointed at yes it's the finger
pointing at the moon it's not the moon
itself
and
and so when we look at
the teachings of the buddha or of christ
or any of the great saints through
history and we go
they had they were saying words that
were just
almost true
yeah yeah
as true as words can be
but then the followers and the people
who wanted to make identities and
communities and power structures based
on those teachings have done all sorts
of
crazy and harmful things and some
beautiful things with those words
but it's not you know i don't think any
particular
buddhism is not
by
the irony of like trying to resist
suffering
that creates suffering like it
[Music]
to
the irony
in almost all these religions if there's
not
an aspect of the religion that kind of
keeps questioning itself which i think
christianity actually does pretty
beautifully and that's what i love most
about christianity now at this point
um
the death of god to god as christ is on
the cross and saying where's god like
that contradiction yeah um
is kind of the same as the doubt that
cannot be spoken to me so when i when
you see it like that and like these are
things
these are concepts in my brain these
little abstract
technologies that i can utilize
to
to what and if
and that's what you can pay attention to
what am i wanting and if i'm wanting to
actually be present to this moment and
be able to say yes and i'm having a hard
time saying yes to this moment some of
these technologies can be incredibly
useful right
because you you're using it well it's a
utility when i'm asking the thing about
a material possession like if i hold up
this timer and the thing that ryan i
often ask with physical things and i
think it starts with the stuff for us as
the minimalist does this thing add value
to my life well that actually springs up
several more questions what does it mean
to add value right like does it serve a
purpose does it bring me joy in some way
does it uncover a happiness that's
already there because the other side of
what you're talking about the the trying
to avoid suffering leads to more
suffering the opposite of that is the
pursuit of happiness actually leads to
less happiness
and
and but if we can use these as a
technology not as a
legalist
prescription
well you must get down to these 100
items and you'll be a good minimalist
and there you therefore you'll be happy
same thing is true with buddhism or
christianity or anything else you if
you're a good christian then all of a
sudden everything is fixed right if
you're a good minimalist then all of a
sudden everything is fixed but of course
as you have alluded to already nothing
is ever fixed right it is ever changing
yeah and this is the sort of through
line through all of it
yeah
this is
isn't is like the least
this is
trying to say words that are the least
false as possible calling it this is
still false yes yeah right yeah j
krishnamurti says i can't tell you
what's true i can only tell you what is
not true
and um
and and that sort of has this double
entendre of a meaning everything that i
say essentially makes it you know some
degree of untruth simply by speaking it
but when we're talking about this we're
not about definition we're talking about
the essence of what we're saying and
we're trying to approximate it with
these damn words because we're on a
podcast and that's all we have
yeah and they're they're great if
they're tools
if they're things if they're
experiences that were willingly and
consciously engaging words are beautiful
and these technologies are just like
what a magnificent
gift that language is to be able to
experience the world in these really
nuanced and sophisticated ways where we
can actually share between bodies these
experiences using words and it's like
it's wild and it's amazing but when we
believe
[Music]
the words we believe our beliefs and we
hold on then that kind of loses the
magic it becomes a dead
abstract thought as opposed to a living
reality yeah
elizabeth i'm going to send you a copy
of michael gunger's book is called this
becoming free if you like podcasts
you'll certainly like the audiobook
version or we can send you the book book
version as well do you have any
questions from our live stream we do we
have a question submitted by shannon
shout out to our patrons by the way
shannon thank you for your support
what's shannon have to say he says i'm
in politics and seeking approval is part
of the job i know i can't make everyone
happy and i do my best to focus on the
importance of the democratic process
what more can i do to show others i care
michael how to gain more approval
yeah isn't that fascinating part of my
job is i guess i mean part of most a lot
of our jobs is probably
seeking approval in some way but so how
can we can we do the job without
believing the job you know what i mean
like yeah right can you can you
have the belief and not believe it can
you can you seek approval without
having any of your
any resistance to how it actually is now
that's that's the real
the real dance and the balance of like
being present
and
even finding a yes under the no because
finding approval looking for approval is
a no right you're going
we don't have enough approval we need to
get more approval so no to how things
are
but can we live from a place of yes
underneath that where the nose are
contained
in the yes and that's the way i
to me yes or god like
when we talk about the totality that
allows all experience to happen
to me like calling that yes is it it is
that's really beautiful because
everything is give is being given a yes
at every moment an opportunity to be
that's a yes and so can we live from
that place of being that is yes
being is yes
and when we're coming at it from being
and seeing that there's absolutely
just like when
when you have a it's like it's like
getting a click back that gives you some
perspective
while you're watching a movie you have
perspective that while the characters
going through their
dilemmas and their disasters that this
is headed that you're also aware that
it's a movie and a story so you're not
lost
if you're if you're lost in the movie
where you believe this is happening and
this is the permanent situation that
this character is real and they're
forever going to be in this predicament
you're going to be tortured it's a
torque that would be a horrible
experience to watch a movie but because
we can easily click back and go on some
level unconsciously like this is a movie
i get i get this a movie there's a thing
going on we got to tell stories and if
you can live from that place in a
political job you're like yeah
i'm playing a game i'm playing a game
where we got to get votes and we need to
people's approval
but you can't
give or take anything real away from me
yeah because as soon as you need it
that's when the suffering and that's
where the i think the crux of this
question
is
i feel as though
hey it's part of my identity i am in
politics i'm a political person and or
whatever it might be and that's not good
or bad but
when as soon as it becomes part of our
identity
then
and you also say what paul so politics
means one thing in our culture right but
but actually the root of it just means
the affairs of the city or the affairs
of the state right
which is a totally different thing right
affairs of the people
well yeah i guess there is some element
of cooperation there but the needing of
the approval will always make us
miserable
and so
it's almost as though
we often ask like
how can i
still need this thing but not be
miserable
but of course that doesn't work
need is a really interesting word isn't
it like an interesting concept because
we it's an unspoken
it makes sense if i
speak the desired outcome if i say
i need
like i want this glass to be closer to
me
so i need to pick up the glass i need to
that makes sense there's like a
a step it's a step that's necessary for
my desired outcome but if we don't say
the desired outcome which most of the
time we do not right
need doesn't make any sense
i don't need anything
by itself right i don't need food
in this moment i don't need food if i
want to keep living and i'd state that
desired outcome i'm going to need food
sometime in the next
several days
but that's only if i want to keep on
living in this body
i have to i have to be aware of
needs don't make any sense we sometimes
just blindly like oh but this is what i
need well why what do you want yes and
we're ashamed of what we want
and if we didn't if we weren't ashamed
if we were just
at peace with oh here's a desire that i
have and for that desire to happen i
need
then then we're
back in the captain's chair of our lives
rather than being like at the whims of
my needs and you know impulses impulses
yeah yeah ryan what time is that you
know what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your
questions and comments to 937-202-4654
now michael this is what we do during
the lightning round ryan and i and our
guests we try to answer questions with a
short shareable less than 140 character
response okay we call them minimal
maxims i like it something pithy that
podcast sean could tweeze out and put in
the show notes so you can copy and share
on social media if you like by the way
you can find all of our minimal maxims
in one place minimalmaxims.com
but here's what we really do we just
monitor on a bit and then sean tweezes
out something pretty
and makes us sound much more profound
than we
actually are
alabama looks like we got a question
here from yuko
i was taught not to be a quitter and had
a weird sense of pride about continuing
to do things even if i didn't enjoy them
how do we accept when it's time to move
on to quit is bad and to keep going is
good right
that's that's that's what was instilled
in yuko here right and we've been told
that you should not quit or you should
carry on and if you were to quit then it
says something about who you are as a
person you're the type of person that we
don't like
oh what a prison that is
quit what you were doing every single
moment
tweet that podcast sean yeah that's good
and what you're really talking about
here is
well that's almost like a an ego death
in a way right
and ego is a big part of
of the book that you wrote
um maybe we could expand on on that a
little bit because sometimes people hear
ego and that word is also used
pejoratively
it's just his ego
right
and understandably so we do a lot of
hideous things to other people
because of our ego
but that's not what you're talking about
necessarily when you talk about ego is
it no
yeah again if you don't have a desired
outcome
there's no
how can you say ego is
good or bad or anything ego
is i mean for me the way i talk about
ego is
it's kind of a constriction that i
identify as myself
it's a no that i've gone oh that's me
that no is me
and
um so me trying to play the pithy game
of saying quit every moment
i think there is an element of every
moment
that
when when we really get present with it
is both the death of all things that
were and the birth of all things that
are
every single moment this is the big bang
that we're sitting in right now this is
the absolute edge of it and the absolute
pinnacle of it
wow and it's also the death of
everything that ever was yes and if we
don't
the temporary the
impermanence
is terrifying to the ego because the ego
is a thought of permanence right
i'm going to hold on to this improve it
make things better
yeah and and we're basically like um
we're trying to polish an ocean wave or
something right
and it just doesn't it doesn't happen
there's a uh a lovely parable in the
book that i've actually used on my on my
daughter in various ways my daughter's
eight
and um
the the catching the ocean wave and
yeah i'll go out and tell her i'm gonna
catch an ocean wave for with a bucket
and she's like oh wow really
yeah
i go out and i grab the bucket and i'll
catch a wave for it i'll bring it back
on to the beach and she's excited to
look in there i don't know what she's
expecting i don't think she knows what
she's expecting wow
and then
you show her and she's like that's not a
wave that's just dirty water bucket of
dirty water yeah
like you don't want to take it home
but like there's also this realization
there of the impermanence and and then
also like the interconnectedness of it
all we call that thing a wave
but it's not a wave yeah
it's the whole ocean doing its ocean
thing yeah responding to the moon and
the yeah all of it yeah
man well i got something pithy for you
and i think it it echoes what your
sentiment was there my pithy answer was
to move on drop whatever is weighing you
down
i think maybe hard expand on that it's
all weighing you down
you know and
and so
we we often
we carry a lot of beliefs with us just
because
well we want to be accepted or just
because we never stop to question the
belief that is no longer serving us
and the belief you have right now yuko
is that
you are a quitter if you stop doing
something
and here's what i'm here to tell you yes
you are and how wonderful is that you
get to quit so many things every moment
is an opportunity
to quit
maybe if there's more in power and
language for you because you have all of
these bad thoughts tied up in quitting
maybe the maybe it's about walking away
maybe it's about letting go you're not a
quitter you're a let-goer
i like that yeah and yeah
you're a bit late
a creator yeah
helpful ways of looking at it maybe more
than quitter yeah space maker right
there are all these ways that are
helpful to you someone else might see
twitter as being empowerful or being
empowering because maybe the culture you
were in is is you were told to stick
through all the time and it made you
miserable now being a quitter for you is
something that is like yeah i want to
have that freedom to be able to quit to
walk away yeah it's what you're really
talking about is a type of freedom
and
and
not being able to quit
is
a jail cell yeah it's its own prison
i i grew up christian and the the
concepts of heaven and hell we used a
lot and the way i see them now
those concepts i used to think of them
as like literal places or something but
i think heaven is
actually life it's it's the livingness
and the impermanence
that's real
and hell is the the illusion of
permanence it is the experience of
permanence it's the experience of
what can you
quit that assumes permanence and assumes
that something would keep existing
for that you who's the you
and what are you quitting like it's your
your when we assign these stories
to reality if you just swirl the bucket
of water and you're like what in here is
quitting
or what is creating or what you have to
realize you have to tell the story it's
just so it's just
everything is impermanent
and we're telling stories about it yeah
so let's tell stories that make
make it fun why not yeah
yes
you know
it's interesting the ego
you have an experience you tell talk
about an experience where you went to a
float tank
and uh you had taken some plant medicine
and i'm so glad you wrote about this
because i've i've thought i wanted to do
this
and you talked about how like hey i
don't recommend you do that
[Laughter]
because you get so separated from your
ego
that it actually caused you like
legitimate harm like physical harm yeah
and i won't like ruin the story for the
i mean i guess we can but but it's
interesting because the ego yeah we do
look at it as a bad thing but it's not
necessarily a bad thing it's not
necessarily a good thing
it's a tool and like we get to decide
how we use it and my pithy answer to um
to yuko here is
to let go is to be free
now that doesn't mean that you let go of
everything
it just it just just understand that
when you let go of something it frees
you from it yeah and so just like the
ego letting go is a tool
it's something that
yes like you don't want to let go of uh
certain things in life like i love my
wife i don't want to let go of that love
i don't want to let go of this
relationship
um not necessarily that i'm clinging to
it but but maybe there's a point where i
would want to let go but it's
you go she can just let go
and understanding
that it does result in this freedom i
mean it might give her a little bit more
leverage to
let go of this belief that
if she quits she's bad
yeah
we were joking via text message this
morning ryan and i were remember
their whole race controversy let's go
brandon thing i'm sure you heard about
this somewhere in the news but
uh
my fantasy was like maybe they're
actually just saying let go brandon
[Laughter]
like it was a real empowering message
yeah right um
and
i think that quite often we get
really caught up people ask us all the
time ryan how
do i
let go
as if there is a three-step plan
and i get it especially with with
respect to materialism okay you can
declutter your stuff you can drive it
down to the goodwill and hand it to them
but that doesn't mean you let go of it
that means you got rid of some stuff
yeah but if you got rid of it and you
still have that attachment to that stuff
you've just increased your suffering now
because now you don't even have that
object of your
desire you've let go of the object but
not the
the the desire
we had a mutual friend on the podcast
peter rollins
and
he sometimes talks about
we quite often think we want to get
certain things we have a desire
it's almost as though we want to get rid
of our desire if i have a desire to buy
a bmw
it's
as soon as i get the desire or as soon
as i get the bmw maybe my desire will go
away but isn't the desire the very thing
that you actually wanted
the whole time or at least thought you
wanted right
and and so as soon as you get it now all
of a sudden that object of your desire
turns into a burden an object of of
discontent quite often
and so
it's not about the
attaining or the achievement of the the
possession or the the status symbol or
the promotion or the hit record or the
number of downloads your podcast gets
because as soon as you get that thing
you thought you won now you've gotten it
you've gotten rid of the desire now a
new more sort of pernicious desire might
creep up in its place
we got so much more to talk about from
alabama you got uh something for us
first here's some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi this is josie from austin texas
ryan talked about replacing his t-shirts
every every year when they were faded
and smelly from also wearing them to
work out
when i have a t-shirt that's looking
worn i move it to my workout clothes and
toss or donate what i've been wearing to
exercise that keeps my regular clothes
in better shape and they last longer
hey josh and ryan alicia from australia
uh just ringing because i
i was listening to your pittsburgh
podcast
and there was a woman there was asking a
question about what to do with her
blanket that an aunt had given to her
and
it was covered with like photos of
her
as like growing up and as a child and
she does not want to keep it
um
and i had a suggestion that she could
donate it to an animal shelter
um any blankets or
you know
old sheets or towels or bedding
and stuff that people want to get rid of
in in their minzing journey
animal shelters are a great option
because obviously the animal's not going
to care
if there's a warm blanket with the
picture of your face on it
um they're just going to be grateful
that they have something warm to snuggle
up into
and have a nice safe sleep
all right y'all big thanks to our new
friend michael gunger for joining us
today check out his book it's called
this also his podcast is called the
liturgists we'll put a link to both of
those in the show notes and his band is
called gunger
and in fact at the end of this for our
added value
today i want to play the first song i
ever heard from
gunger it's from their 2013
album the album's called i am mountain
it's the title track it's also the
opening track on that album
it's called i am mountain but before we
get to that added value segment ryan
real quick for right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in the
life of the minimalists i hope you speak
german
nine
wait a minute that's the ultimate
paradox
anyway um our book love people use
things which i'll hold up for the camera
here it's available in two dozen
languages now ryan
you are so popular
all across the world this one is german
what does this say on the back uh
alabama up at the top there yeah vinegar
that means less is more oh wow look at
that wow can you read a a passage for us
by chance is there anything not even a
passage maybe just the back cover here
yeah from alabama not warm up my german
articulators there before you get
started on that so the book you just go
to the minimalists.com
foreign you can see all the different
languages so it's in slovenian and
slovakian okay our two biggest ones
clearly
uh it's in portuguese in brazil spanish
and french and italian and now german
it's also in dutch and a bunch of other
languages as well alabama do you have a
german excerpt from love people use
things for us sure i'll read the back
here venegas mayor
we sound way more uh
way more of an authority in german yeah
we're very aggressive in germany
and what does the subtitle say so it's
love people use things because the
opposite never works that's the english
what does this say in in german alabama
in german the subtitle is viole das
gegental nicht fuente
which is like because the opposite does
not work or does not function because
the opposite does not function that is
very german
consult your local library or your local
bookstore in whatever country you're at
you can go to the minimalists.com
foreign to find
all two dozen different languages that
love people use things and many of our
other books are now available in
ryan for added value this week let's
check out i am mountain by gunger
by the way we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week like i have a strong
belief that it's disrespectful to get
rid of something if someone else took
the time and money to give it to me how
do i let go of this belief and make
decluttering less emotionally draining
what steps can i take to develop freedom
from old beliefs opinions and worldviews
once i realize they no longer serve my
well-being and how can we maintain peace
when loved ones question our beliefs
plus a million more questions for
michael and the minimalist and if you
want to check out all that check out the
minimalist private podcast this week
visit patreon.com
the minimalist to subscribe and get your
personal link so that our weekly private
podcast plays in your favorite podcast
app you'll also gain immediate access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
recordings of live events exclusive home
tours and our private community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers like
you you can follow the minimalists on
tiktok instagram facebook and twitter at
the minimalist if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com on
behalf of ryan nicodemus podcast sean
alabama jordan no more social jess danny
unknown emma the immigrant and the rest
of our team i'm joshua fields milburn
reminding you to love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it
bye